Le fait de rendre la drogue illégale n'empêchera pas les gens de la consommer.
Notre incapacité à voir les choses différemment
se base aussi sur un discours totalement erroné vis-à-vis de la toxicomanie.
On nous incite à croire que les toxicomanes
sont des personnes irresponsables qui veulent juste « planer »,
et qui, par leurs propres échecs personnels,
finissent par tomber dans le crime et la pauvreté,
en perdant leur travail, leur famille et, au final, jusqu'à leur vie.
En réalité, la plupart des toxicomanes ont une histoire,
que ce soit un traumatisme de l'enfance, des abus sexuels, une maladie mentale
ou une tragédie personnelle.
La drogue sert à engourdir la douleur.
Nous devons le comprendre lorsque nous leur faisons face.
Notre politique anti-drogue est d'abord une question de justice sociale.
Si les médias se concentrent sur les morts par overdose comme Michael Jackson,
cette souffrance
concerne surtout des personnes marginalisées,
pauvres et dépossédées de leurs biens.
Ces personnes ne votent pas et sont souvent seules.
Ce sont les individus jetables de notre société.
Même au sein des services de santé, la toxicomanie est très stigmatisée.
Les toxicomanes évitent le système de santé.
Ils savent que lorsqu'ils recevront des soins,
ou qu'ils seront admis à l'hôpital, ils ne seront pas bien traités.
Et il leur sera impossible de se procurer leur héroïne, leur cocaïne
ou leur méthamphétamine.
De plus, on les assaillira de questions
qui ne servent qu'à révéler leurs échecs et leur honte au grand jour.
« Quelle drogue consommez-vous ? »
« Depuis quand vivez-vous dans la rue ? »
« Où sont vos enfants ? »
« Quand êtes-vous sorti de prison ? »
En résumé : « Pourquoi n'arrêtez- vous pas la drogue ? »
En vérité, toute notre approche médicale vis-à-vis de la drogue est erronée.
Pour je ne sais quelle raison,
nous avons décidé que l'abstinence était le meilleur traitement.
Si vous êtes chanceux, vous serez admis à une cure de désintoxication.
Si vous vivez dans une communauté avec Suboxone ou de la méthadone,
vous serez peut-être admis à un programme de substitution.
On n'offre jamais à ces gens ce dont ils ont vraiment besoin pour survivre :
une prescription sûre d'opioïdes.
Exiger l'abstinence, c'est comme demander à un diabétique d'arrêter le sucre,
à un asthmatique de faire des marathons
ou à un dépressif d'être heureux.
Pour d'autres maladies,
jamais nous ne commencerions par l'option la plus extrême.
Pourquoi pensons-nous que cette stratégie
marcherait avec une chose aussi complexe que l'addiction ?
S'il y a toujours eu des overdoses accidentelles,
l'ampleur de cette crise est exceptionnelle.
Le Centre pour le contrôle des maladies a estimé
que 64 000 Américains sont morts d'une overdose en 2016,
dépassant de loin les accidents de la route et les homicides.
La drogue est à présent la première cause de décès
chez les hommes et les femmes âgés de 20 à 50 ans en Amérique du Nord.
Pensez-y.
Comment en sommes-nous arrivés là, et pourquoi maintenant ?
Toutes les conditions d'une crise sont réunies autour des opioïdes.
Des médicaments comme Oxycontin, Percocet et Dilaudid
ont été distribués pendant des dizaines d'années comme antidouleurs.
On estime que deux millions d'Américains consomment des opioïdes chaque jour,
et plus de 60 millions de personnes
ont reçu au moins une prescription d'opioïdes l'année dernière.
Ce déversement massif de médicaments sur les communautés
a fourni une source régulière de produits pour l'auto-médication.
En réaction à cette épidémie de prescriptions,
on a largement coupé à ces gens l'accès à cette source.
La conséquence involontaire, mais néanmoins prévisible,
est une épidémie d'overdoses.
Beaucoup de ceux qui comptaient sur la constance des médicaments prescrits
se sont tournés vers l'héroïne.
Le marché des drogues illégales est malheureusement passé
aux drogues de synthèse, en particulier au fentanyl.
Ces nouvelles drogues sont bon marché, puissantes et très difficiles à doser.
Ces gens sont littéralement empoisonnés.
Que se serait-il passé pour tout autre type d'intoxication à grande échelle ?
Et si des milliers de personnes mouraient
à cause de viande, de café ou d'alimentation pour bébé empoisonnés ?
Nous déclarerions l'état d'urgence,
et fournirions immédiatement des solutions sûres.
Il y aurait des changements dans la législation,
et nous soutiendrions les victimes et leur famille.
Mais pour l'épidémie d'overdoses,
nous n'avons rien fait de tout cela.
Nous continuons à diaboliser la drogue et ses consommateurs
et nous plaçons aveuglément toujours plus de ressources dans la répression.
Alors que devrions-nous faire à présent ?
D'abord, nous devons totalement adopter, financer et étendre
les programmes de RDR dans toute l'Amérique du Nord.
Je sais que dans des lieux tels que Vancouver,
la RDR a été indispensable aux soins et aux traitements.
Je sais que le nombre de décès par overdose
serait bien supérieur sans la RDR.
Et je connais des centaines de personnes qui sont en vie aujourd'hui
grâce à la RDR.
Mais la RDR n'est que le début.
Si nous voulons vraiment avoir un impact sur cette crise,
nous devons remettre en question la prohibition des drogues
et les sanctions pénales.
Nous devons reconnaître que la drogue est d'abord un problème de santé publique
et nous tourner vers de vraies solutions sociales et sanitaires.
Nous avons déjà un modèle à suivre pour réussir.
En 2001, le Portugal était en proie à sa propre crise de la drogue.
Un grand nombre de toxicomanes, une criminalité élevée
et une épidémie d'overdoses.
Ils ont défié les conventions mondiales et décriminalisé la possession de drogue.
L'argent qui était investi dans la répression
a été redirigé vers des programmes de santé et de réinsertion.
Les résultats sont là.
La consommation moyenne de drogue a chuté de manière drastique.
Les overdoses sont rares.
De plus en plus de gens suivent un traitement.
Et ces gens ont pu reprendre leur vie en main.
Nous avons tant persisté sur la voie des sanctions et des préjugés,
que nous sommes devenus indifférents à la souffrance
que nous infligeons aux personnes les plus vulnérables de notre société.
Cette année, il y aura encore plus de personnes à être mêlées
au trafic de drogue.
Des milliers d'enfants apprendront que leur mère ou leur père
a été envoyé en prison pour avoir pris de la drogue.
Et bien trop de parents seront informés
du décès par overdose de leur fils ou de leur fille.
Ce n'est pas une fatalité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)